we're joined now by texas governor greg
abbott governor good to see you great of
you to be here a lot to get to
including mask wearing in schools uh the
american academy of pediatrics is
suggesting that
kids as young as two years old should be
masked up when they go back to school in
the fall
what do you plan to tell people in your
state
well first the setup and that is what
you all have been talking about the past
few minutes and that is
all the information that we get from
washington dc and the supposed leaders
about responding to covet have been as
john talked about earlier
shifting they keep moving the goal post
throughout the entire pandemic and all
that really does is
so confusion among the american public
no one knows what to believe
and as a result people have lack of
trust and confidence
in the information coming out of
washington dc the one thing that we do
know is this
and that is that those who receive
covert vaccine shots
are far less likely and highly protected
against
far less likely to get coven highly
protected against covet
and so the state of texas is working
with local communities to make sure
that people are have access to covert
shots and are aware
of the success rate of kobush shots with
regard to schools in particular
listen i've made it very clear this is
an issue of parental
choice and will not be an issue of
mandates
especially for those who have already
received a copic shot there's absolutely
no proven reason for them to be required
to wear a mask for one but for another
again there will be no mandates in texas
schools
about wearing masks but as always
the people who are most responsible for
the health of their children
are the parents and the parents have the
right uh
to make sure that they will get to make
the choice about whether or not their
child will be wearing a mask in school
it seems that there's there's so much
more thought put into just
that aspect of things and not what
happens to these kids if they do
have to wear a mask all day if that
takes away from their socialization
their ability to learn
uh heading into multiple years of this
i saw sort of a reaction to the rand
paul dr fauci exchange that we've played
there at the top of the hour there was
more
uh that came from all this including
this exchange with dr fauci
and the cdc director wolinski and it
pertained to exactly what we're talking
about right now wearing masks in schools
in the fall listen it is my priority to
get our children back to school for safe
in-person learning we continue to
recommend that schools
implement layered prevention strategies
to protect those who are not fully
vaccinated and encourage vaccination for
those who are eligible
masks continue to be a critical part you
know i'll get your reaction to that
while i put this headline up on the
screen dr marty mccary
a wall street journal editorial saying
the flimsy evidence behind the cdc's
push to vaccinate children the agency
overcounts
covet hospitalizations and deaths and
won't consider if one shot is sufficient
this isn't important to point out
because he is saying that they need to
make more
informed policy decisions when it comes
to
government officials he says they're
they're working with
nearly 30 000 employees at the cdc but
they're working off incomplete or flawed
data
why is there not an effort to have more
data behind these decisions rather than
just throwing stuff out there sometimes
that has to either be taken back or
changed so quickly
you know from the beginning of the
response to the pandemic to what you're
talking about today
the approach has been ready fire aim and
they shoot before they really know
exactly what they're talking about and
then they have to go back and retract
what they've said before and redo it and
again this is why
the american public is losing trust and
confidence with regard to the
recommendations coming out of washington
d.c
and that sandra is one of the reasons
why there is some level of vaccine
hesitancy because
the public doesn't trust what's going on
with regards to whether it be the
vaccines or the recommendations
and as a result it is going to be a
requirement that
it's going to be decisions made by
parents uh they're in the best interest
of their family as well as their kids
okay i want to move on to these texas
democrats who fled your state but before
i do
so no change to mass mandate for your
state as of now uh
neither for the public or the schools
okay so these texas democrats a 6-1 now
has tested positive for the coronavirus
governor
is the is the clock is ticking are they
going to run out the clock here
what happens next as far as the sweeping
election the sweeping election bill back
at home what is your
next step as they're still there
well first you can obviously tell what
the democrats have done is a disaster
of a trip up to washington dc that has
accomplished uh absolutely nothing
uh and while at the same time uh think
about this uh
they they have abandoned their job been
in their responsibility to engage in the
debate to try to shape
this election integrity bill while they
were gone in washington d.c the texas
senate
did pass out an election integrity bill
and i have to emphasize this
the democrats who remain in texas
working in the texas senate
they were able to work to make
amendments
to that bill that would be more to their
liking that is exactly what
the texas house democrats could have
done had they remained in austin texas
as opposed to wasting their time in
washington d.c because they have been in
their responsibility
when they get back to texas i will be
calling another special session
and put this back on the agenda as well
as so many other items that are so
important
to their constituents their constituents
are getting mighty upset
about the fact that their house member
is not in the state of texas doing the
job they were elected to do
another completely different story with
them
contracting the virus and showing up at
the white house and uh
having access to nancy pelosi and others
on capitol hill now a staffer of nancy
pelosi's has tested positive
and a staffer at the white house i want
to ask you about the border crisis we
have seen the numbers governor
they are staggering we've seen the
images
of these migrants flowing over our
southern border
brand new numbers out show that that is
still at a record high
obviously coronavirus also playing a
part here as we are now learning a large
percentage of those migrants
are now reporting that they do and are
carrying coronavirus
over the southern border what are you
doing about
a wall can you really build one
no we can and i will mention that but
let me first touch upon the last thing
that you said and that is
as we're speaking the president is
considering lifting title 42 that
president trump put in place which was
to prevent people coming
into texas from mexico or coming into
the united states from mexico
because of the kova situation it is
going to be
a disastrous political and policy
decision if the president lifts that
the president bears personal
responsibility for every single american
who gets
sick or contracts covey because of
people coming across the border
and and he needs to be called out on
being so reckless
in considering lifting title 42 with
regard to your other point
listen we've already begun the process
of building the border wall as well as
adding barriers
with regard to building the border wall
we're under the process of hiring a
project manager
we are already receiving offers and
information
from those who've already been involved
in building the border wall showing the
ways that we're going to be able to
build it
we've already we've already made an
allocation of funding by the state
legislature
we will be adding to that allocation of
funding to make sure that we're able to
build the border wall
but i must add this there there is a
need
that will be provided for far greater
number of additional personnel on the
ground because texas is changing the
model real quick senator and that is
we're not doing catch and release
anymore the state of texas is working
with local officials
we're going to be arresting people
coming across the border
and we will be putting them in jail they
will not be getting the red carpet
treatment
they've been getting under the body
administration i have to leave it there
governor please check back in with us
appreciate you giving us the time
thank you sandra